Alright here is the setup: I have a rifle
mounted vertically and we're going to shoot
a bullet into this block, right into the middle
of it.
So obviously the block is going to go flying
into the air.
But we're going to do this again and instead
of firing the bullet right into the middle
of the block, we're going to shoot it off
to one side and I want you to make a prediction.
Will that spinning block, when we shoot hit
it to one side, will it go the same height
as this first block?
Will it go not as high?
Or will it go higher?
OK so versus being shot in the middle, when
you shoot on the side is the question, right?
Yeah.
How high will it go in comparison?
It depends on if the bullet stays in the block
- and I'm assuming it does?
It does stay in the block, yes, I'll guarantee
you that.
Same height.
I'm purely basing it on just like an instinct
that I have.
I feel like I'm being tricked.
I just feel like you're trying to trick us
and that it's going to do something that we
can't predict.
I feel like the obvious answer is not as high
so I'm going to say higher.
I'll say higher, but it's going to like fly
in a different direction or something.
So you have angular momentum, which is L,
and you have translational momentum, which
is P. When you hit it in the middle of the
block, the block doesn't really spin at all
so it just goes up to a certain height.
But when you hit it on the side of the block,
it's going to be spinning so it's going to
have imparted some kinetic energy so there
won't be as much potential energy.
So the total energy of the system basically
has to stay constant and the kinetic plus
potential, which would be the height it goes
to will have to be constant so if it's spinning
it has kinetic energy, it can't go as high.
That's my prediction.
So my prediction is it'll go up, not as high
but it'll spin more if it's hit to the side.
Am I wrong?
I want you to think which do you think is
the most reasonable and then click one of
the annotations above.
Alright are you ready?
Make your prediction in three, two, one...